بدعوا كلمات على مكعب اسمنتي كافيه لتغيير
القانون وتحديد مصير مئات العائلات
الفلسطينيه اما بالتهجير او انهاء الوجود
انها منطقه عسكريه مغلقه للتدريبات واطلاق
النار ممنوع الدخول
في المنطقه التي يمنع القانون العسكري
الاسرائيلي الدخول اليها عشرات التجمعات
الفلسطينيه عائلات تعيش هنا منذ مئات
السنين قصص وحكايا رجال ونساء واطفال
وبيوت هدمت مرات ومرات وظل اصحابها
يحاولون البقاء ان لم يكن فوق الارض فربما
تحتها كما يفعل عامر دبابسه الذي هدم بيته
واصيبت قدمه في اخره هجوم اسرائيلي ليذهب
لحفر مغاره وتجهيزها لاواء عائلته لعل
باطن الارض يقهره سطحها المغاره
صعب الحياه فيه بس لان انا بدي اتعايش مع
الوضع اللي انا فيه وبدي يعني اضل موجود
في الارضي سكان وخلت الضبع بضروره اخلاء
منازلهم وان الجيش الاسرائيلي سيبحث لهم
عن بديل بالاضافه ثمانيه تجمعات اخرى
يقطنها نحو الفنسمه اقرت المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه ان باستطاعه اسرائيل ان تضع
يدها عليها واخلاها كونها منطقه عسكريه
خاصه بالتدريبات بعمليات الهدم كانت
متكرره ترجع على الاشجار بدا يعني يطلع
فيها كانت متكرره عندك من الكهرباء
المنطقه العسكريه او مناطق تدريب الناس في
هذه التجمعات لا يصدقون ذريعه المنطقه
العسكريه وخطرت تدريبات لا سيما وهم
يشاهدون المستوطنات القريبه منهم تنمو
وتتكاثر مؤسسات الحقوقيه وقانونيه تسعى
لمساعده السكان بالتوجه الى المحاكم
الدوليه
لثاني اسرائيل عن عمليه الاخلاء وتهجير
التي يبدو انها وشيكه مع ابلاغ الارتباط
الاسرائيلي نظيره الفلسطيني ان الناس سوف
يبلغون وقريبا بضروره الاخلاء وان اسرائيل
سوف تجد لهم بديلا اخر للعيش من منطقه
مسافر يطا عبد الحفيظ جعوان العربيه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه